no let's not get into this I don't wanna
get I just need to say that heard of the
dunning-kruger it's when people are so
certain that they are skilled at
something actually not having that skill
sure that's the dunning-kruger effect
what skill does he think you have stand
up he open for me in Irvine and can I
just say this it was like it was almost
as if I went to Africa right and I just
went into a kid and a kid who had the
big belly as a starving starving
dehydrated and just brought oh monsters
and got to stand up yeah you do better
than him I've this guy right here right
oh my god he came we were we knew that
he was gonna do stand-up he drove all
the way to a vine and we had her to try
things out with her things out our
friend our phones out right and and we
weren't laughing at first Kazuki was
eating it so bad that's great but then I
remember what I say to you later
oh you that was like five minutes in but
also I'm assuming the crowd knew who he
is they have an idea yes now if you try
that at like the comic store with no one
knows who you are
yeah you're not gonna last five minutes
I know that wasn't the worst part when I
was do some cross been awesome he
thought he did brilliantly he's one of
those yeah you're not one of those no
that's how you know how you know how I
can tell you're not you know I can tell
you're not one of them but because
you're um you're self-conscious about
super self-conscious about you because
that one used to started going to comedy
clubs we even talking to you could feel
that you were kind of self-conscious
like you know I mean yeah I'm doing it
you know I mean a punter on the football
right you're right come on the sense
right yes so maybe you're more like an
empath so you can sort of gauge I'd
rather be a guy to go I bombed then I
killed there's nothing I did I have a
trigger when people died dude I just
killed that them well let me talk to the
audience I know all right
easy bill yeah yeah because I've seen
but here's the other thing is it's maybe
maybe it's why I've got more I've got I
guess fast quote unquote but at the Calm
a storm I'm watching the best of it be
like if you're like I'm gonna try
basketball let me just go check it out
this all-star game
holy [ __ ] these guys are good like
that's the left that's another reason
why my hats are off to you because
you're now going to these places
I told us the Rappaport to Michael right
before cuz he was nervous one time we're
behind in the main room he seemed a
little nervous I'm like yeah but do your
in this is the a this your Jeremy you're
competing be more nerve-wracking I think
it's way more nerve-wracking his nerves
should be worse yeah yes and your should
be too though 100 procedures you're
playing yeah I don't understand how you
do that like because I was raised in
that room I've been in that in the
comedy store since 1997 yeah right so I
know every facet I know everyone that's
played there I know I've done the
Tonight Show
Yeah right so I've don't brag but yeah
it was a bragging okay you know I'm just
giving you facts
I know I know this alright yeah you
[ __ ] good I know you're a thick face
going on would you do the Tonight Show
right now different time right Jimmy
Fallon know you know you know who's
bigger than all those shows Joe Rogan I
know if do you know what Johnny Carson
is Joe Rogan yeah I know and he hasn't
asked me I haven't done his show and I
bet you if you do a semester you will
know you don't think you don't think
other comics are frustrating I'm doing
special well I think that's one of the
reasons why he doesn't have me on that's
what I'm saying because he's frustrated
he's frustrating I had frustrate him
that's what I'm saying you've hated
everyone why do I prefer you you don't
frustrate me I want white said I want
greatness for you I think if you did a
special it would absolutely crush I
think if you're on Netflix it would blow
people away
it's so [ __ ] dumb I'll tell you a
dummy you guys are gonna take a dummy
warm please do
Kalen does the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
different animal to put cameras at
Callen Cal dead Bryan Callen well code
amigos man you have so much potential
potential yeah yeah and I look at my
house potential I know I know but I'm
late because he's people trying to
motivate me I'm not trying to motivate
people try to motivate me that's what
I'm trying to do it right you have a
great saying I'm sorry you'd have to do
anything
[Music]